bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir nous
interpelle sur une faillite nationale
bonsoir Stéphane Simon et merci d'être
là votre enquête sur les derniers jours
de Samuel Paty chez plomb est absolument
glaçante dans les dysfonctionnements les
errements les errants de
l'administration sont nombreuses dans
cette tragédie qui aurait dû être évité
votre site d'information a révélé la
lettre de la soeur de Samuel Pathy
Michaël Paty et elle débouche ce soir
sur l'ouverture d'une commission
d'enquête parlementaire on va y revenir
longuement dans le détail dans la
deuxième partie mais on commence ce soir
par l'immigration c'est le dossier qui
revient en force au cœur du débat public
avec d'abord le contre projet des
républicains face à celui de Gérald
Darmanin et puis un pays le Danemark
coûte tout le monde se presse et où ce
sont les socio-démocrates au pouvoir qui
mène la politique la plus ferme en
Europe en matière d'immigration on verra
avec
quels résultats modal ou mirage grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
avant de retrouver les parties prix de
nos affranchis et puis Bourbon Express
bien sûr comme chaque soir l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le
programme vous me suivez Stéphane Simon
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
Stéphane Simon n'hésitez pas à
intervenir c'est un sujet qui intéresse
forcément le citoyen que vous êtes et
même à interroger nos invités la parole
d'abord pour commencer à la mi Stéphane
blackovski qui propose quoi et pourquoi
ce sujet revient en force il a deux
secondes le chrono de Blacko c'est parti
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors ce dossier de
l'immigration alors est-ce que quelqu'un
a compris quelque chose à la position du
Gouvernement sur l'immigration parce que
moi j'avoue que j'ai un petit peu de mal
ils ont démarré bille en tête en juillet
dernier juste un mois après législative
Gérald darmin disait attention dès la
rentrée une loi pour expulser les
délinquants étrangers bon sauf que une
semaine plus tard bah finalement plus de
loi sur l'immigration reportée à ciné
dit bon vous savez qu'on décourage pas
Gérald Darmanin aussi facilement il a
donc réussi à déposer son projet de loi
immigration au Sénat en disant que ça
allait arriver à l'Assemblée pas du tout
voilà que Elizabeth borne dit ah non
c'est pas le moment dans des battre ça
pourrait diviser le pays donc c'est le
chef du gouvernement c'est elle qui fixe
le cap et donc qu'un jour plus tard elle
dit exactement le contraire moi je
repose ma question est-ce que quelqu'un
a compris la politique non c'est pas
facile donc les LR évidemment une
occasion en or ils sont sortis en vrac
de la réforme des retraites pour refaire
leur union et vous allez voir qu'ils ne
se sont pas gênés pour faire la une du
JDD sur ce thème de l'immigration avec
un plan bien à eux
[Musique]
et vous savez que j'ai toujours eu la
même ligne le même discours oui il y a
trop d'immigrés aujourd'hui en France
par rapport à notre capacité
d'assimilation de ces étrangers alors
est-ce que les LR vont réussir à
s'entendre avec Gérald Darmanin il y a
un peu de suspense et l'intérêt de la
politique mais chacun montre un peu ses
muscles là c'est Olivier Marleix qui dit
écoutez si le projet que Gérald Darmanin
propose à la rentrée sur l'immigration
ne nous paraît pas suffisant et ben on
renverse le gouvernement on l'écoute des
Français ne supporteraient pas qu'on
fasse semblant et que les politiques
fassent semblant avec une 22e loi sur
l'immigration qui ne change rien qui
permettrait juste au gouvernement de
dire ça y est on a coché la case donc si
le gouvernement s'amuse à ce petit
journal ce petit jeu là à faire semblant
et essaie de passer en force sur ce
texte avec un 49-3 oui on déposera une
motion de censure
alors je vais vous laisser débattre vous
savez que le CP c'est la chaîne où on
prend un peu de recul donc oui 75% des
Français trouvent 9 migrés mais quand on
leur demande c'est pas non plus leur
préoccupation principale et
l'immigration il y a d'autres choses
notamment le pouvoir d'achat qui les
préoccupe pas mal la santé la protection
sociale l'environnement l'éducation mais
ce soir c'est débat immigration merci de
remettre les choses dans leur bonheur
merci Stéphane je vais me tourner
d'abord parler vers les politiques
Charles si une stould c'est vrai que
quand on regarde 21 lois immigration en
20 ans pourquoi il faut légiférer à
nouveau franchement pourquoi pour durcir
davantage l'arsenal actuel parce qu'on
voit que c'est un sujet de préoccupation
pour nos concitoyens et le premier
sondage qui a été montré les les
résultats sont éloquents moi ça
correspond à ce que j'entends et je vois
chez moi en Alsace dans ma
circonscription il y a une préoccupation
il y a des inquiétudes des Françaises et
des Français sur le sujet migratoire et
je pense et je le dis comme député de la
majorité présidentielle
il y a une attente forte d'une majorité
de nos concitoyens il y a une attente
durcir encore donc la législation et
donc il faut répondre à cette attente
donc vous voulez durcir ça vous
l'assumer quelle est la philosophie de
votre projet de loi pour comprendre et
pour débattre
c'est la façon dont Gérald Darmanin et
Olivier du soft on présentait les choses
depuis quelques mois il y a
sur le sujet de l'asile sur le sujet du
je dirais du volume de l'immigration
qu'on est en capacité à accueillir
là-dessus il faut durcir et ensuite le
sujet de l'immigration économique où là
il faut beaucoup de pragmatisme parce
que les milliers de chefs d'entreprise
dans notre pays nous disent qu'ils ne
trouvent plus de main d'oeuvre et que si
on veut continuer à faire tourner
l'économie française on doit faire vomir
des personnes régularisées et qui vont
s'intégrer pour le travail donc c'est un
sujet de grands pragmatisme intégration
d'un côté et régularisation donc par le
travail pour pallier la pénurie parce
qu'elle existe cette pénurie d'emploi et
dans beaucoup de secteurs il suffit
d'aller écouter le Medef et il le dit
Guilhem Carayon fermeté de l'autre ça
vous convient pas
bien nous non plus on n'a pas compris le
projet du gouvernement et c'est parce
qu'on l'a pas compris qu'on présente le
nôtre on part de trois constats le
premier c'est qu'il y a une explosion
des flux migratoires depuis quelques
années en 2022 il y a 500 mgalement
illégalement légalement sur le
territoire national ces deux fois la
ville de Bordeaux c'est l'équivalent de
la ville de Toulouse deuxième constat il
y a une volonté populaire qui est nette
qui est très claire et vous l'avez
montré à peu près tous les électorats
même ceux du PS même ceux d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts sont majoritairement
pour une politique migratoire plus
contrôlée plus restrictive alors nous on
pense qu'il faut en finir avec
l'impuissance il y a eu vous l'avez
montré 21 lois en la matière depuis 20
ans on peut pas se contenter d'une
nouvelle loi il faut modifier la
Constitution c'est le seul moyen pour
reprendre le contrôle pour retrouver
notre souveraineté juridique en matière
migratoire et je crois que même si c'est
pas le thème prioritaire pour les
Français évidemment c'est la question du
pouvoir d'achat c'est quand même un
thème essentiel et les Français sont
très clairs sur la question on va
revenir dans le détail sur ce que vous
proposez Béatrice Giblin c'est
intéressant parce Nintendo deux élus
enfin notre député et représentant de
les républicains jeune républicains nous
disent les Français les attentes des
Français et donc on revient au sondage
70% estiment qu'il y a trop d'immigrés
en France un peu plus même comment vous
vous comprenez ce sentiment vous avez
travaillé notamment sur sur 100 Gates à
Calais sur la jungle de Calais qu'est-ce
qu'il dit la longueur de sondage c'est
c'est un sentiment c'est l'unité du pays
qui serait menacée dans dans son
identité qu'est-ce qu'il signifie déjà
le terme d'immigrés et n'est pas précis
pour eux je suis très très surprise que
Éric Ciotti puisse parler d'immigrés et
dire que les immigrés sont des étrangers
il y a une grande partie des immigrés
qui sont français on peut parfaitement
être arrivé étranger en France et avoir
obtenu la nationalité française donc on
est immigré de nationalités françaises
donc déjà parlé d'immigrés comme ça sans
préciser je trouve ça absolument
stupéfiant de la part de quelqu'un
président d'un parti qui fut grand et
qui se trouve même dans un département
les Alpes-Maritimes où il est confronté
à des arrivées effectivement d'étrangers
qui sont passés par l'Italie bon donc
c'est déjà pour moi le signe quand même
de la confusion dans lequel quand on
parle de cette console quelle question
est-ce qu'il y a trop d'étrangers les
réponses seraient les mêmes mais trop
trop d'étrangers oui sans doute parce
qu'il pense que les gens qui ont la
nationalité française mais qui sont
noirs ou qui sont arabes sont resteront
des étrangers dans leur représentation
ça c'est un contestable pour une partie
des Français pas pour tous les Français
soyons raisonnables là aussi si vous
posez la question il y a trop
d'étrangers ou trop d'immigrés vous
allez avoir la réponse oui si vous dites
et bien voilà on bloque l'immigration
mais à ce moment-là la retraite ce sera
65 ans 67 ans parce que si on enlève
tous les gens qui bossent et il va
falloir que ce soit les autres qui qui
se mettent à travailler je suis pas sûr
qu'on est forcément le même enthousiasme
pour nous d'attention au sondages en
revanche là où je pense que c'est
important si vous voulez c'est peut-être
parce que je suis géographe mais la
répartition le fait que l'île de France
reçoivent à peu près la moitié en fait
des primo arrivants c'est beaucoup dans
ce et soyons sérieux ils arrivent pas
dans le 16e ni dans les Hauts-de-Seine
ils arrivaient essentiellement
Seine-Saint-Denis dans le Val-de-Marne
c'est-à-dire dans la petite couronne et
que donc ça pèse j'ai enseigné 30 ans à
Saint-Denis donc je l'ai vu je l'ai
constaté c'est primo arrivant avec une
noria parce que les primo arrivants
effectivement ils ont besoin d'entraide
ils ont ils arrivent ils connaissent
quelqu'un de leur village ou de la
famille on vient là où ça va être un peu
moins difficile mais à partir du moment
où ils sont trouvés un emploi le femmes
ou les enfants sincères on sort de ce
lieu là parce qu'on a envie d'aller dans
quelque chose de plus agréable donc on
est à une noyade primo arrivant
constamment ce qui pour la population
autour elle sentiment que c'est une
invasion constante et qui arrive et donc
c'est la question de l'urbanisme c'est
la question de la ghetto vous mettez en
concentration qui est extrêmement
importante que vous posez il faut
essayer de raisonner non pas une échelle
globale mais
plus précisément pour comprendre comment
en tout cas ça pose bien votre votre
regard dans ce débat Richard werli vous
qui suivit des questions européennes il
y a une proposition choc dans les
propositions de loi notamment celle qui
veut réviser la constitution des
républicains c'est celle qui permet si
elle aboutissait évidemment de déroger à
la primauté des traités sur le droit
européen frexit migratoire à digérald
Darmanin ça reviendrait vraiment à ça
de fait un énorme problème je
rappellerai même que c'était alors ça
n'amènerait pas à sortir de l'Europe
mais ça poserait un réel problème
institutionnel que Michel Barnier
candidat rappelez-vous à la présidente
de la République avait déjà proposé il
était prêt à assumer ça donc c'est pas
nouveau chez les républicains de
d'adopter cette logique de confrontation
vis-à-vis des institutions européennes
peut-être quand même juste un chiffre au
niveau européen pas au niveau français
comme je savais que j'avais mis à cette
émission j'ai regardé Eurostat en
février de cette année puisque les
statistiques sont toujours légèrement à
retard vous avez 600 5 personnes qui ont
demandé qui ont fait une application
pour l'asile en Europe dans l'Union
européenne et les premières nationalités
étaient les Syriens les Afghans les
Colombiens et les Vénézuéliens pourquoi
je dis ça c'est parce que il faut voir
que la géographie migratoire européenne
c'est une géographie qui tient compte
des situations géopolitiques par exemple
aujourd'hui il est très clair qu'on va
avoir dans les mois à venir une arrivée
massive de soudanais ou de gens en
provenance du Soudan et ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que ce que disent les
républicains en France ce que dit Gérald
Darmanin au fond il faut bien
reconnaître qu'ils sont à l'unisson de
l'Union européenne parce que certes les
républicains courts un risque de choc
institutionnel avec l'Union européenne
mais l'Union européenne en ce domaine
s'est énormément durci vous avez 5
textes aujourd'hui qui ont été approuvés
en avril dernier par le Parlement et qui
doivent encore l'être par le Conseil
européen tous ces textes visent tous à
restreindre les demandes d'asile sur le
territoire
de la migration économique dans la
majorité comment on regarde au fond ce
choc à droite sur l'immigration parce
que vous dites que vous voulez durcir
vous avez fait déjà deux lois depuis
qu'Emmanuel Macron a été élu est-ce que
vous allez jusqu'à penser que l'État de
droit doit s'adapter à cette question là
alors au sein de la majorité il y a un
débat sur le sujet migratoire c'est très
très clair et il y a plusieurs
philosophies il y a plusieurs
orientations alors moi je viens des
républicains donc moi je me situe plus
sur le pôle de droite de la majorité il
y a des choses que vous pourriez
reprendre avec la droite
que à ce que nous travaillons encore
plus avec les républicains sur sur tous
les sujets dans la Constitution mais
dans la Constitution ça ça vous pourrez
pourriez voter ça je vois pas trop ce
que ce que ça changerait honnêtement les
modifications constitutionnelles qui qui
sont proposés déjà et je rappelle qu'il
faut les faire voter parce que changer
la constitution ce sont des majorités
dépend de vous Cali qualifiés pas que
d'ailleurs ça dépend de vous de nous
mais pour changer changer
vous en avez quand même un peu plus ça
valait au-delà de l'addition de la
majorité présidentielle et des réponses
il y aura d'autres forces
politiques
nous négocions pas avec eux et donc moi
je suis quand même assez prudent sur les
propositions des républicains d'ordre
constitutionnel je suis pas sûr que
c'est ça qui va changer
président de la commission des lois de
votre partie Renaissance n'est
absolument pas sur cette ligne là voilà
donc il y a déjà un problème d'accord et
de lignes au sein même des Macron au
sein de la majorité sur ce sujet moi je
voulais ajouter j'espère que les
prochaines semaines qu'on aura
permettront d'en discuter aussi c'est
que sur les les faits migratoires
l'immigration qu'on a connu en France
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale a
quand même profondément évolué il y a
quand même deux faits dont il faut que
je puisse qu'on débatte au Parlement à
l'Assemblée d'une part il y avait en
gros 5% d'immigrés dans la population
française au sortir de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale aujourd'hui c'est le double
c'est quasiment 10% et ça c'est quand
même un changement dans la population
française qui est important et dont il
faut pouvoir discuter de façon très
sereine et je pense qui explique en
partie les sondages qu'on a vu deuxième
c'est l'origine de cette immigration
jusqu'au milieu des années 70 en gros
deux tiers de l'immigration étaient
d'origine européenne et aujourd'hui
l'origine de l'immigration que nous
avons en France et pour moitié d'origine
africaine c'est un changement profond et
j'espère que là aussi c'est ces deux
faits très importants ces données
viennent de l'Insee elles sont
incontestables il faut pouvoir en
discuter et en tirer des conséquences
d'une immigration qu'on peut intégrer
une autre qu'on n'arrive pas à intégrer
c'est ça que vous nous dites plus
compliqué plus compliqué
observent au jour le jour moi je pense
que il est de
bon ton ou on répète à l'infini
l'intégration de marche pas l'ascenseur
social est bloqué pour avoir enseigné je
leur ai dit de nouveau 30 ans
Seine-Saint-Denis dans une université
j'ai bien vu que l'intégration
fonctionnait qui est dératé qui est des
sérieux difficultés qui est de la
délinquance qui est du trafic de drogue
et que ça concerne pour une part non
négligeable des jeunes
issus de l'immigration mais bon sang de
soi
cette immigration elle n'est pas toute
en situation de difficulté loin de là si
vous prenez simplement vous allez à
l'hôpital vous regardez les noms des
chefs de service regardez les noms des
chefs de service ils auront des
consonances qui seront très souvent des
consonances maghrébines pour beaucoup
ils sont tunisiens ils sont algériens
ils sont libanais ils sont si rien
heureusement qu'ils sont là pendant le
covid si vous prenez certains les gardes
des
urgence vous voyez bien que vous avez
des internes qui eux sont d'Afrique
noire qui ont fait leurs études alors on
peut regretter qu'ils ne soient pas au
service de leur de la population du pays
dont ils sont originaires mais ils sont
là mais vous prenez des avocats vous
prenez des professeurs vous prenez donc
ce discours si vous voulez constant
comme si je trouve ça extrêmement
méprisant pour cette pour cette
population
le Danemark a commencé par faire
inscrire dans sa constitution que le
droit national devait primer sur le
droit européen c'est ce qu'a fait le
Danemark on oublie de le rappeler avec
donc
par ailleurs pardonnez-moi je crois
qu'il y a personne ici qui est contre
farouchement l'idée de l'immigration
simplement ce que demande les Français
et ce que personnellement je trouve
intéressant c'est simplement de pouvoir
légiférer et simplement contrôler un peu
le flux migratoire ça veut pas dire le
stopper ça veut dire simplement d'abord
estimer qu'il faut avoir une démarche
volontaire pour devenir française avoir
la France au cœur c'est au moins la
moindre des choses il y a pas un pays
dans le monde qui ne demande pas à ce
que c'est immigrés qui arrivent et
fassent une démarche très volontaire ce
que fait la Suisse est absolument
remarquable il demande à tous ceux qui
postulent à la à devenir citoyen suisse
1 de maîtriser la langue deux de
maîtriser la Constitution 3 d'être en
capacité de comprendre les différentes
régions etc c'est à dire qu'on demande
vraiment
dans un instant vous comparez des pays
très différents des nôtres c'est pas les
mêmes populations et Richard werliquez
en sait quelque chose alors on va se
rendre à Copenhague et puis ensuite vous
allez pouvoir débattre faut-il
s'inspirer du modèle danois je vous le
disais c'est le plus fermé d'Europe en
matière d'immigration erikiotti en
revient d'ailleurs tout comme Olivier
Véran qui s'est rendu il y a quelques
semaines alors reportage regardez
à Copenhague voici le chantier qui fait
polémique dans ce quartier la majeure
partie des habitants est d'origine
étrangère selon la mairie il n'y aurait
pas suffisamment de mixité alors elle a
pris une décision radicale cédée au
privé la moitié de ses logements sociaux
et expulser les habitants actuels pour
les reloger ailleurs
Mohamed Aslam vit ici depuis plus de 40
ans ce chef d'entreprise parfaitement
intégré sous le choc
Mireille
pourquoi devrions-nous être chassé de
nos maisons mais quatre enfants qui sont
nés ici ont grandi ici ont reçu une
bonne éducation ils ont un travail
pourquoi sommes-nous rangé dans la
mauvaise catégorie de la population
un plan anti ghetto initié par le
gouvernement qui multiplie les mesures
contre les étrangers
confiscation des biens à l'arrivée sur
le territoire accès restreint aux
allocations expulsion en cas de
manquement à la loi tout est fait pour
décourager les immigrés de venir ou
rester au Danemark
Mezian est arrivé d'Iran il y a un an et
pour obtenir un permis de travail cette
médecin doit passer un examen qui va
bien au-delà de ses compétences
professionnelles les questions portent
aussi sur l'histoire et la société
danoise
c'est très difficile pour moi parce que
si on veut être intégré à la société on
ne peut pas à moi de parler parfaitement
le Danois
es qui viennent en aide au réfugiés
s'inquiète de cette dérive
on a de terribles en particulier des
jeunes qui se sont réfugiés pour qui ça
se passe très bien au Danemark faisons
des amis danois ils parlent danois et on
leur dit de rentrer chez eux c'est
stupide c'est un immense gâchis et c'est
inhumain
le Danemark a négocié une dérogation
près de l'Union européenne pour avoir
plus de souplesse en matière de
politique migratoire résultat depuis
2015 le nombre de demandeurs d'asile a
été divisé par 10 fait surprenant c'est
la gauche qui a pris toutes ces mesures
et qui justifie sa politique au nom de
la défense d'un certain modèle social
quand on parle d'intégration c'est
comment les gens peuvent travailler
mettre leurs enfants à l'école apprendre
la langue comprendre notre société le
nombre de personnes compte et si nous
avons trop de personnes à arriver en peu
de temps c'est impossible de les
intégrer correctement
une stratégie soutenue par une majorité
de danois
voilà pour la situation au Danemark où
vous l'avez compris c'est le centre
gauche qui même cette politique initiée
au départ par la droite Guilhem Carayon
vous reprenez tout deux petites
observations avant de parler de la
situation et Danemark que j'ai entendu
sur l'immigration serait en soi un
problème non c'est pas du tout le cas
l'immigration est un problème devient un
problème quand elle est massive et quand
le pays d'accueil n'a pas les capacités
pour intégrer plus même qu'intégrer pour
assimiler les personnes qui viennent sur
le territoire naturel des médecins dans
les hôpitaux on parlait dans la
restauration dans le bâtiment
2022 il y a pas eu 500 000 étrangers qui
sont venus
dans notre norme suprême qu'est-ce qu'il
signifie nous concrètement contrairement
à ce qu'a pu dire le ministre de
l'intérieur on veut pas sortir de
l'Union européenne en revanche on entend
pas que l'Union européenne Déroche à la
lettre de ces traités qui prévoit le
respect de l'identité continuelle de
chaque nation qui compose l'Union
européenne
d'exécuter davantage les les OCC les
obligations à quitter le territoire mais
sur l'assimilation qu'est-ce que c'est
dans la Constitution concrètement
l'assimilation c'est déjà un principe
qui est dans le Code civil nous on veut
le constitutionnaliser comme on veut
constitutionnaliser d'autres principes
la question des quotas par exemple on
pense que chaque année absolument je
sais pas moi avoir un travail la
simulation c'est quoi c'est avoir un nom
français qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
c'est pas l'aspect plus important des
deux textes l'aspect le plus important
c'est la logique des quotas
il y a différentes mesures et celle qui
est fondamentale c'est la question des
quotas combien d'étrangers on est
capable d'accueillir chaque année sur le
territoire national nous on pense que ça
doit être beaucoup moins que ce qu'on
fait actuellement et ça doit être en
fonction de nos capacités d'accueil là
où on a besoin évidemment qu'on peut
continuer à accueillir des gens des
médecins à l'hôpital évidemment qu'on a
besoin en revanche est-ce qu'on a besoin
d'avantage de personnes qui vont qui
vont pas réussir à s'émanciper qui vont
pas réussir à trouver un emploi parce
qu'on voit d'ailleurs que il y a
énormément d'étrangers il y a une
surprenation des étrangers dans les
chiffres du chômage
regroupement familial quasiment
inexistant maîtrise de la langue et de
l'histoire on l'a vu obligatoire pour
être régularisé pays où on peut être
même forcé de déménager famille
étrangère afin de renforcer la présence
danois dans certains quartiers le
Danemark c'est pas la France Richard
Verdi est-ce qu'on doit est-ce qu'on
peut s'en inspirer oui quelques
remarques j'entendais tout à l'heure
c'était 26 mon cités par exemple la
Suisse qui est un peu plus proche de la
France que le Danemark et qui est un
système que je connais bien je crois que
en matière d'immigration ou plus
exactement en matière d'arrivée
d'étrangers en situation irrégulière
parce que c'est quand même en gros ça le
problème principal il faut comparer ce
qui est comparable le Danemark n'est pas
sur les routes d'arrivée massive
aujourd'hui des étrangers en situation
irrégulière en Europe le Danemark a une
position qui lui a permis de prendre un
certain nombre de mesures je pourrais
dire la même chose de la Suisse on la
Suisse du fait de sa position
géographique n'est pas exposée à des
flux massifs trois éléments juste trois
remarques premièrement il y a une chose
que de toute manière la France quel que
soit les textes dont elle se dot elle
n'y échappera pas c'est les chocs
migratoires lorsque les gens arrivent à
vos frontières qu'ils arrivent en bateau
qu'ils arrivent dans les conditions
qu'on sait ça on y échappera pas et avec
le réchauffement gérer ça ou alors sinon
il faut accepter que des gens meurent à
vos frontières ou les renvoyer dans des
situations absolument infernal j'arrive
de graisse vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qui est la police grecque est accusée de
renvoyer des gens ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose quand on dit il
faut s'affranchir des règles européennes
le problème c'est que c'est justement
dans un certain nombre de situations les
instruments européens qui peuvent
permettre de réguler les flux
migratoires
globaux non je vais parler des retours
si vous voulez obtenir des pays
d'origine l'acceptation de ces étrangers
en situation irrégulière il faut un
levier le levier c'est la plupart du
temps l'aide au développement
aujourd'hui l'essentiel de l'aide au
développement et les données par l'Union
européenne autrement dit ce n'est pas
parce que vous êtes la France que vous
allez obtenir de tel pays qu'il reçoive
vos réfugiés il faudra que ce soit
l'aide européenne qui entre en jeu on a
besoin l'Union européenne même chose si
vous voulez gérer des centres d'accueil
qu'on appelle pudiquement en Europe les
hotspots aux frontières extérieures de
l'Europe ça ne peut être fait que sur
des fonds européens avec l'Union
européenne donc cette idée de
s'affranchir du droit européen je n'y
crois pas du tout parce qu'on a des
dizaines de l'Union européenne est-ce
que seulement surprenant que vous y
croyez pas puisque de toute façon vous
répétez je dirais des choses qu'on
entend depuis très longtemps et qui
manifestement n'ont pas je rappelle
quand même l'assistance que Michel
Rocard qui dit on ne peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde c'est il y a 40
ans depuis 40 ans les recettes que vous
posez sur la table elles n'ont pas
véritablement fonctionné pardonnez-moi
il y a cinq textes aujourd'hui qui ne
sont sans doute pas parfaits mais qui
sont examinés au niveau européen je dis
juste une chose c'est que l'idée ce que
l'idée derrière s'affranchir des textes
européens c'est qu'on pourrait mieux
résister aux flux migratoires et aux
chocs migratoires quand on est seul
l'expérience démontre
il faut le droit national ce qui est une
question de souveraineté c'est la même
chose pas du tout que le droit national
prime sur le droit européen ce n'est pas
s'affranchir immigration danoise pour
les moyens mais les moyens les moyens je
vous citer des dizaines d'exemples de
pays qui s'en sortent très bien
migratoire mais vous n'êtes pas alors
parlons de la Suisse puisque vous voulez
mais pourquoi non
et pareil vous allez comprendre que je
comprends que le Danemark ne vous plaise
pas
c'est que la population danoise
aujourd'hui massivement est pour se
poursuive cette politique migratoire
on sait tous que l'immigration
incontrôlée c'est un carburant pour le
rassemblement national au Danemark il
était à 20% aujourd'hui c'est attendez
attendez il est 3% pour un parti destin
droit il y en a deux autres qui existent
aussi et cela fait que en fait si vous
prenez l'ensemble de ces trois parties
d'extrême droite il n'est pas à 3%, il
est à 15 %. donc il a été baissé il a
été baissé de 7 points mais il n'a pas
été baissé de 22 à 3 puisque l'argument
des nouveaux partis d'extrême droite qui
se sont qui sont
je ne dis pas qu'il faut accueillir
toute la misère du monde je dis pas ça
et je ne pense pas que ce soit si facile
que ça si vous voulez que les frontières
soient des passoires et que tout le
monde arrive très très facilement et
qu'on accueille tout le monde après
ouvert je ne pense absolument pas les
conditions parce qu'on parle de ce
médecin vous avez raison de dire qu'il y
a des gens qui réussissent dans notre
société sont arrivés il y a peu de temps
mais pensez aussi aux migrants qui sont
portes de la chapelle qui vivent sous
des tentes et je pense que quand on ne
peut pas offrir des conditions de
spatialité on a bien compris
et qui s'installe à Paris
essentiellement bon la moitié d'entre
eux on constate quoi pour essayer de les
répartir sur l'ensemble du territoire
les Afghans ils acceptent tout de suite
de partir en région les Syriens ils
acceptent tout de suite de partir en
région là où c'est beaucoup plus
difficile c'est quand vous avez déjà on
va dire un groupe
issu du pays dont vous venez qui est
installé en région parisienne pour cela
c'est extrêmement douloureux de partir
et en particulier par exemple on prend
l'exemple des Turcs les Turcs qu'on a
énormément de mal soit ils sont en
Alsace à la rigueur soit ils veulent
absolument rester en région parisienne
donc on a une très très grande
différence de comportement dans
l'acceptation de pouvoir aller en région
en revanche une fois que c'est en région
quand les choses sont bien préparés non
pas comme ce qui s'est passé à
pourquoi parce que les gens se rendent
compte que c'est arrivé là soit permet
d'avoir des jeunes dans l'équipe de foot
comme ça s'est passé dans l'Inde et
l'équipe de foot qui était plus de
centenaire le club allait fermer est
arrivé c'est c'est réfugiés demandeurs
d'asile joueur de foot de trois nations
4 nations différentes et ça a sauvé le
club tout le monde trouve ça formidable
ou quand on permet de garder une école
ouverte une classe ouverte les gens
changent leur représentation donc vous
avez raison ce qu'on voit dans des
tentes portes de la chapelle est
absolument intolérable seulement il ne
faut pas penser que l'État ne fasse rien
pour ces gens-là soit il essaye de les
mettre dans des centres et une partie
d'entre eux
accepte de se déplacer une autre partie
va quitter parce qu'il est pas question
qu'il parte en province c'est une
question alors extrêmement difficile et
si à bien juger ou le yakafocon c'est
celui-là bon allez on va laisser la
parole aux politiques pour terminer ce
débat qui s'achève dans moins de 1
minute trente il y a quand même un
projet de loi on est à l'Assemblée
nationale sur la Chaîne Parlementaire
vous vous dites c'est apprendre ou à
laisser ça veut dire quoi très
concrètement vous avez 60 députés donc
vous n'êtes pas au pouvoir donc ça
abandon à laisser oui c'est bien gentil
mais en gros si le gouvernement met pas
son texte de loi ça veut dire il y aura
rien ça veut dire qu'on fait un cadeau
gouvernement et on leur propose un texte
qui est plébiscité par 80% des Français
c'est les sondages de la semaine qui
l'ont montré si vous le reprenez
dialoguer j'ai l'impression quand même
il y a des passerelles entre vous deux
évidemment qu'on peut dialoguer mais
nous on obser le gouvernement le reprend
les Français auront un texte migratoire
très précis très puissant pour retrouver
notre souveraineté si vous le faites pas
et si vous franchissez certaines lignes
rouges notamment par exemple la
régularisation massive des clandestins
pour vous donc pas de possibilités pour
pallier à la pénurie d'embauche ça sera
toujours non de régulariser par le
travail sur les métiers il y a une
solution qui est beaucoup plus simple
plutôt que de régulariser des
clandestins des gens qui sont de manière
illégale sur le territoire nationale on
peut faire venir chaque année des
immigrés pas dans les quantités
évidemment comme ça a été le cas depuis
quelques années mais on les fait venir
dans les métiers en tension évidemment
qu'il y a des besoins simplement
beaucoup de pays simplement la logique
de quota elle répond à cette
problématique là en revanche régulariser
des gens qui ont rien à faire sur le
territoire français parce qu'ils sont
illégaux évidemment que non vous avez
entendu c'est la deuxième jambe dans les
projets de loi il y avait gentils avec
les gentils c'était le contrats métiers
en tension méchant avec les méchants
c'est les mots de Gérald Darmanin cette
première jambe ça passe pas à droite
donc à priori c'est bloqué vous ne
pourrez pas
je sais que Gérald Darmanin a vu ce
matin François nolbuffet qui est le
président et l'air de la commission des
Lois du Sénat je crois qu'il verra
Gérard Larcher dans quelques jours
il y a une voix de passage j'espère
qu'on pourra trouver un accord sur ce
sujet migratoire voilà les Français
attendent qu'on durcisse nos politiques
publiques en la matière et moi j'y suis
favorable et bien sûr de très près sur
LCP merci pour ce débat Stéphane Simon
vous y étiez carrément parti prenante
merci à vous non vous avez totalement
raison c'était l'idée merci d'être venu
débattre sur LCP vous restez donc avec
moi Stéphane Simon dans une dizaine de
minutes les parties primes nous
affranchis ce soir le regard de Vincent
Hugo sur le double retour en grâce de
Bachar el-Assad et Mohamed Ben Salma au
sommet de la Ligue arabe de Jeddah
l'oeil sur le numérique de Delphine
Sabatier avec la condamnation historique
de méta de Mark Zuckerberg on verra ça
sur les transferts de données et puis
uberfe Elizabeth borne face aux députés
ce sera dans Bourbon express avec Elda
Elsa mon dingava à tout à l'heure les
amis mais d'abord on va plonger dans
votre enquête Stéphane Simon je le
disais
vous le fils de professeur et bien vous
retracez minutes par minute les 11
journées qui ont précédé la décapitation
de Samuel Paty faillite des services
administratifs faiblesse de
l'institution scolaire c'est une enquête
glaçante sur une tragédie qui dites-vous
aurait dû auraient pu être évité on voit
cela dans l'invitation de Diane
karchermo et on en parle tous les deux
juste après
si on vous invite Stephen Simon c'est
parce que vous jetez un pavé dans la
mare avec ce livre les derniers jours de
Samuel Paty dont le sous-titre annonce
la couleur en quête sur une tragédie qui
aurait dû être évité tragédie qui a pour
vous une résonance très personnelle
Stephen Simon vous êtes journaliste de
presse écrite vous couvrez notamment les
faits divers avant de devenir producteur
de Thierry Ardisson et entrepreneur
toujours dans les médias mais vous êtes
aussi intimement liée à l'école
républicaine vous qui êtes fils
petit-fils et même arrière petit-fils de
professeur vous le dites le massacre de
Samuel Paty je l'ai vécu comme celui
d'un des miens votre obsession
comprendre comment on est arrivé le 16
octobre 2020 à l'assassinat d'un
professeur d'histoire-géographie parce
qu'il avait montré une classe de 4e des
caricatures de Mahomet paru dans Charlie
Hebdo
les faits sont connus mais vous voulez
aller plus loin vous vous livrez à une
autopsie méthodique du drame pour
traquer les failles les errements qui
l'ont rendu possible vous le faites à
travers un compte à rebours des 11
derniers jours de Samuel Paty on voit la
spirale mortifère se mettre en place
sous nos yeux comment un simple cours
sur la liberté d'expression est
instrumentalisée par des islamistes qui
n'hésitent pas à divulguer l'identité du
professeur et attiser la haine contre
lui dans une vidéo sur les réseaux
sociaux jusqu'à l'irréparable ces
informations tombent sous les yeux d'un
candidat au jihad abdullahran sorov un
jeune tchétchène d'appendent 18 ans qui
l'assassine à la sortie de
l'établissement scolaire Samuel Paty
fut la victime de la conspiration
funeste de la bêtise du mensonge de
l'amalgame de la haine de l'autre de la
haine de ce que profondément
existentiellement nous sommes tout ça
sous les yeux d'une hiérarchie
impuissante lente et gênée aux
entournures un encéphalogramme
administratif plat après céder la
tempête écrivez-vous c'est même pire
vous montrer des autorités académiques
prompt à rejeter la faute sur Samuel
Paty qui aurait froissé les familles
musulmanes en montrant les caricatures
leur incapacité à le protéger ou tout
simplement à le mettre en retrait face à
des menaces graves d'islamistes
pourtifier s menace également
ignorer ou sous-estimé par les services
de renseignement bref ce sont vos mots
c'est une faillite nationale alors
aujourd'hui Stéphane Simon nous avons
envie de vous poser une question
avons-nous tiré les conséquences de cet
échec
réponse j'ai bien peur que la réponse
soit non j'espère que la commission
d'enquête qui était décidée il y a
quelques heures par le Sénat va
permettre de porter la lumière sur un
certain nombre de responsabilités mais à
l'évidence aujourd'hui non le drame qui
a frappé cette ce professeur
d'histoire-géographie pourrait
recommencer et pire que ça vous savez
que depuis cette affaire c'est devenu
malheureusement une figure de style dans
certains lycées il y a des élèves qui
menacent leur professeur de leur faire
une Samuel Paty on peut pas on peut pas
la mémoire alors vous l'avez dit il va y
avoir une commission d'enquête
parlementaire sur exactement ce qui
s'est passé sur cette enquête elle va
être faite d'une certaine façon et ça va
tout changer parce que c'est aussi
vis-à-vis des Français qui va y avoir
voilà une forme de mobilisation du pays
tout entier c'est votre site factuel qui
a permis de rendre public la lettre de
Michael Paty la sœur de Samuel Paty on
va en écouter un extrait et
c'est Michael Patty qu'il a lu pour
Europe 1 ce matin
l'attentat contre mon frère ne ressemble
pas aux autres attentats il ne s'agit
pas d'un coup de tonnerre dans un ciel
serein à défaut de connaître l'agresseur
le lieu où le moment où il a géré il me
semble évident qu'il fallait protéger la
cible désigner publiquement sur le
fondement d'information connu de tous le
9 octobre 2020 la descente aux enfers de
Samuel aura duré 11 jours et nul ne
pouvait l'ignorer
les responsables ne pouvaient semer
prendre sur la gravité et la constance
du péril ni sur l'imminence de son
agression
bienverti ils se sont pourtant abstenus
d'agir dont agit d'une manière
totalement inefficace eu égard à leur
connaissance moyen et capacités il
faudra bien un jour établir toute la
vérité sur cette histoire pour éviter
effectivement tout récidive l'État ne
peut pas bafouer la valeur sociale ou
morale de la loi qui est censée
s'appliquer à tous l'État ne peut
s'affranchir du principe de
responsabilité qu'il est la base du
droit civil en se créant une immunité de
fait voilà
c'est toujours sa colère à rentrer très
très et très impressionnante voilà
l'état ne peut pas s'exonérer de ses
responsabilités vous l'avez eu au
téléphone depuis l'annonce par Gérard
laché de cette création de commission
d'enquête échanger quelques quelques
mots par messagerie je crois qu'elle est
extrêmement je dirais satisfaite mais ça
veut pas dire grand chose quand on quand
on recherche la vérité c'est un long
processus forme de soulagement peut-être
en tout cas
l'espoir qui vient de s'ouvrir alors on
va revenir sur les éléments de votre
enquête d'abord vous parler de scandale
d'État faillite national ça c'était dans
le sujet mais vous allez plus loin
scandale d'État les mots sont
extrêmement forts pour vous être évité
absolument ça veut dire que notamment
sur la question des renseignements
il y a eu il y a eu des failles très
importantes très content très important
il y a plusieurs niveaux de failles il y
a un niveau qui est de ne pas repérer ce
tueur qui est candidat au jihad depuis
un certain temps qui a été signalé une
quinzaine de fois sur la plateforme
Pharos qui est une plateforme de
signalement d'appel à la haine
d'homophobie etc tout espèce de
d'horreur numérique on va dire et
quatre signalement le dernier week-end
mais 12 avant donc vous voyez c'est un
certain nombre et ça n'a pas été traité
par la direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure il y a une autre faillite
c'est la protection la protection qui
aurait dû avoir lieu qui aurait pu être
décidé par le ministère de l'Intérieur
il y a un certain nombre de journalistes
en France qui sont pourtant la
principale du collège de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine du bois d'aulne
vous le racontez très bien elle essaye
elle se démène d'une certaine manière
pour dire attention d'ailleurs ce
professeur ne va pas bien il est sous
pression il est menacé et le collège
d'une certaine façon l'est aussi comment
se fait-il qu'il n'a pas été protégé il
a pas été protégé parce que précisément
la brigade territoriale des Yvelines n'a
pas cru à la réalité de ces menaces ou
alors a eu des consignes on ne le sait
pas moi je n'ai pas la solution à son
inaction mais en tout cas pour eux
c'était à faire en cours rien à dire
rien à déclarer et surtout ses
fonctionnaires étaient en capacité sans
aucun formalisme de décider de la mise
en retrait de sa melpathie je rappelle
qu'on est à quelques jours des vacances
de la Toussaint et qu'il suffisait
d'appeler Samuel Patty et ils en ont
l'autorité pour dire à Samuel Paty reste
chez vous restez chez vous partez en
vacances prenez quelques jours et on
aurait
sauvécu la solitude même s'il y a
collègue il vous le racontait c'est
important de le dire parce qu'il a été
lâché par pratiquement tous les
enseignants sauf quelques-uns non je
dirais que il y a des collègues qui ont
été
correctes avec lui au-delà même
puisqu'ils ont une manifesté une
certaine solidarité avec lui il y a des
collègues qui ont été odieux avec lui je
pèse mes mots et on découvrira alors du
procès que certains d'entre eux ont
outrepassé ce que j'appelle la
bienséance et un rapport normal dans ce
type de de configuration de crise et
puis il y a l'écrasante majorité des
professeurs qui n'ont été ni plus ni
moins que un peu indifférent ou un peu
inquiet préférence se tenir à l'écart de
tout ça pour rappeler quand même quelle
enseignant c'était il savait
parfaitement dans ce cours d'éducation
morale et civique que la question de la
liberté d'expression du droit au
blasphème c'était un sujet compliqué à
aborder et sensible c'est quelqu'un qui
au contraire même à tout fait pour avoir
la délicatesse de l'aborder mais de
l'aborder quand même
bien de le rappeler c'est quelqu'un qui
est délicat dans son approche c'est un
laïque apaisé je le rappelle ce n'est
pas du tout un militant de la laïcité ce
n'est pas un violent ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui choque c'est quelqu'un qui
fait attention et qui a à cœur de faire
un cours didactique donc le fameux jour
le lundi 5 octobre et le mardi 6 octobre
quand il fait ce cours devant ses 4e il
tire un grand trait à la craie blanche
sur le tableau noir et d'un côté ces
jeux je suis Charlie et les arguments et
de l'autre côté c'est je ne suis pas
Charlie et la projection des caricatures
de Charlie Hebdo ne durera que quelques
secondes et il aura aussi la délicatesse
que certains lui reprocheront du reste
de dire et bien si ça ne vous convient
pas de regarder ça vous pouvez le lundi
sortir puisqu'il y a une assistante de
vie scolaire qui est là vous pouvez
sortir dans le couloir il y aura cinq
élèves qui sortiront le lendemain
simplement il y a pas d'assistante donc
vous pouvez détourner le regard il faut
dire aussi que ces cours se sont passées
admirablement bien il n'y a aucun
trouble il n'y a aucune discussion ou
contestation dans les classes et tout
part pourtant d'une faillite news d'un
mensonge de sel
Zora vous c'est un c'est un nom
d'emprunt qui n'était même pas présente
il faut le rappeler à ce cours-là et qui
va dire vraiment tout sauf la vérité sur
ce qui bien sûr c'est une élève qui
problématique et la 12 inscriptions sur
son cahier de correspondance depuis le
début de l'année en l'espace d'un mois
c'est elle se bat à la cantine avec la
nourriture elle refuse de porter le
masque à la en classe enfin et puis elle
va se faire virer et la principale
annoncé son renvoi et du coup elle va
inventer l'histoire en disant que c'est
parce qu'elle n'a pas voulu sortir alors
qu'on stigmatisait les élèves musulmans
que elles se retrouvent virée ce qui
était fait qui est une pure affabulation
qu'elles sont père va croire dur comme
faire et alors où on se parle il y croit
encore alors c'est très intéressant
aussi sur les parents d'élèves qui font
carrément la loi dans dans le collège on
se souvient de se perd de la fameuse
aura du rôle qu'il aura de l'imam
islamiste siffreaoui et qui sont
d'ailleurs mise en cause il y aura un
procès
expliquez-nous au fond aujourd'hui
pourquoi ce collège n'arrive pas à
s'appeler Samuel Paty ça ça me ça me
fascine comment c'est possible après
tout ça il y a eu d'autres enquêtes la
vôtre est fondamentale qu'on n'arrive
pas à nommer par le nom de ce professeur
ce collège là on va peut-être avoir des
bonnes nouvelles prochainement ah bon
oui peut-être pas très bien vous dire
pour le moment mais j'ai l'impression
que ça bouge j'ai l'impression que ça
bouge j'ai l'impression que on a des
bonnes nouvelles en ce moment il y a des
l'ouverture de la commission d'enquête
ou mission d'information c'est pas
encore
de gens qui prennent conscience que la
meilleure manière de faire progresser
les choses ce n'est pas de vouloir
planquer systématiquement la poussière
sur le tapis et qui a de il y a un
moment il faut savoir se retrousser les
manches travailler ensemble essayer de
trouver des solutions et avancer c'est
comme ça et l'affaire Samuel Paty est
l'occasion d'une catharsis pour tout le
monde pour qu'on puisse enfin se dire
que les professeurs parce que moi j'ai
fait ce livre aussi pour eux ce livre
parce que je suis un fils de professeur
petit-fils etc mais il se trouve que je
pense à eux parce que on ne peut pas
laisser les professeurs se débrouiller
avec tous les problèmes du monde ils ont
besoin d'avoir des conditions
matérielles mais aussi de sécurité
morale de pour assurer leur mission
pédagogique évidemment cette commission
d'enquête parlementaire et vous
reviendrez si vous le souhaitez sur sur
ce plateau les derniers jours de Samuel
Paty enquêtes sur une tragédie qui
aurait dû être évité c'est-à-dire chez
plomb c'est une certaine façon une
faillite nationale c'est aussi
l'histoire de de nos petites lâchetés
cette décapitation atroce merci à vous
vous restez avec moi parce que c'est
l'heure à présent des partis pris de nos
affranchis on les accueille tout de
suite vous allez pouvoir réagir
bienvenue à vous les affranchis et on
commence avec Bourbon Express bonsoir
Vincent et je bien sûr bonsoir Delphine
Savatier préparez vos cartes blanches
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par exemple bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vais
vous parler d'un très beau casting alors
c'est pas le Festival de Cannes c'est
bien ici à l'Assemblée nationale
regardez dans cette journée Olivier du
soft ministre du Travail Clément Beaune
qui est lui ministre des Transports la
première ministre Elisabeth borne et
puis ces dernières semaines Manuel Valls
Bernard Cazeneuve donc d'anciens
ministres toutes ces personnalités
politiques elles ont été auditionnées
dans le cadre d'une commission d'enquête
celle sur les rues les révélations du
beurfy alors d'abord rappelez-nous
exactement ce dossier uber file alors
uberfall ce sont des documents qui ont
été transmis à la presse par un lanceur
d'alerte Marc mcgane qui travaillait
pour uber et qui a démontré bien un
lobbying très intense de la marque
américaine en France notamment et des
documents qui ont été révélés donc par
la presse avait en avant des rendez-vous
avec l'ancien ministre de l'économie de
l'époque un certain Emmanuel Macron
évidemment c'est pour ça que les
insoumis qui n'ont pas oublié de faire
de la politique ont décidé d'enquêter
sur le sujet ici à l'Assemblée il y a eu
plus de 60 auditions des syndicats de
taxi des syndicats de VTC il y a eu
aussi les journalistes à l'initiative
des révélations on a vu donc on l'a vu
d'anciens ministres des ministres
actuels et puis c'est auditions ils se
sont terminées il y a quelques heures
avec le PDG du beurre en personne en
visio et puis des dirigeants aussi de la
multinationale elles sont terminées ces
auditions au grand dames de Daniel
Simonet qui aurait aimé continuer à
auditionner Daniel Simonet c'est la
rapporteur de la commission d'enquête
qui vous vouliez auditionner pour quelle
raison et qu'est-ce qu'on vous a répondu
je souhaitais auditionner monsieur
Lacresse monsieur colère parce que en
tant que membre du cabinet d'Emmanuel
Macron quand il était midi de l'économie
c'est eux qui ont notamment travaillé à
ces relations entre les dirigeants du
maire Emmanuel Macron et qui donc ont
joué un rôle central il refuse qu'on les
auditionne et il refuse ces icitions
pourquoi à votre avis mais parce qu'il
protège les amis de Macron et ça c'est
une acceptable parce que c'est vraiment
empêcher le travail de la commission
d'enquête parlementaire c'est un
problème démocratique alors il c'est le
président de la commission d'enquête ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que c'est
interdit normalement de refuser une
commune le rapporteur de la commission
d'enquête exactement il est c'est Daniel
simonel insoumise mais le Président il
est dans la majorité c'est lui Benjamin
Haddad il a donc le choix de décider de
la liste des invités et il nous explique
pourquoi il n'a pas voulu et bien
répondre aux exigences de Daniel Simonet
vous savez ce que dit Daniel Simonet
plus largement les insoumis c'est que
vous voulez protéger le président de la
République en interrogeant pas son
entourage vous c'est pas du tout votre
version mais moi je comprends que le
récit complotiste et politicien que la
France insoumise a fait de ce sujet
depuis longtemps ce soit dégonflé qui
est une certaine déception de leur part
vous vous dites quand on choisissant
cette commission d'enquête ils ont voulu
faire de la politique en ciblant
Emmanuel Macron bien sûr il y avait
évidemment une logique complotiste
sensationaliste qui s'est dégonflé
maintenant pour autant moi je pense que
c'est une commission d'enquête qui a été
très utile très intéressante alors
quelles vont être les conclusions
finalement de cette commission d'enquête
alors on le sait ça a été démontré
effectivement
uber s'est livré en France comme
ailleurs à un lobbying très intense pour
s'implanter Emmanuel Macron il a
rencontré des dirigeants du beurre il
s'en est pas vraiment caché il a même
dit qu'il était plutôt favorable à ce
genre d'entreprise innovante après on
peut pas forcément dire qu'uber a eu un
énorme traitement de faveur en France le
débat il est pas sur la légalité ou non
mais plus c'est un débat politique parce
que les insoumis dénoncent l'ubérisation
de la société pour eux c'est une
précarisation et elle est mais manuel
Macron en est un des responsables
maintenant leur rapporteur elle va
s'appeler comme son nom l'indique à
faire un rapport sauf que on va le voir
il y aura certainement des dissensions
avec le président de la commission
d'enquête ce rapport après il sera
soumis au vote de tous les membres de la
commission et on verra qui signera voilà
début juillet merci beaucoup Elsa
c'était limpide on enchaîne avec vous
Vincent eugieux l'international bien sûr
vous vouliez revenir sur cette attelage
sur ces doubles retours en grâce la
rencontre entre Mohamed Mel Salman et
Bachar el-Assad c'était à Jedi quelques
jours
du cynisme d'autres moins candides les
diplomates revenus de tout et les
machiavels de la géopolitique en chambre
en chambre de torture le cas échéant
invoque à l'inverse le primat de la Real
politique il n'empêche la réhabilitation
sur les chéquiers oriental du criminel
de guerre syrien Bachar al-Assad le
retour en grâce planétaire du prince
héritier saoudien
deux obscénités pour le prix d'une dans
cette scène datée du 19 mai offre un
saisissant raccourci à la faveur du
sommet de la Ligue arabe de Jeddah le
second MBS accueille le premier Bachar
réintégré au sein de Sénacle 12 ans
après avoir été exclu rançons à l'époque
de la répression aveugle d'une rébellion
civique bientôt supplantée par les
assauts des insurgés djihadistes au
passage l'héritier de la dynastie à ça
doit sa survie à son tuteur iranien et à
son parrain russe entre red aérien et
carnage vaguemerien allusion à la milice
pas au compositeur il en 500 000 tués au
bas mot et plus de 12 millions de civils
réfugiés au déplacés c'est donc sur un
monseau de cadavres que l'assassin et
les carisseurs dansent leurs funeste
tango les carisseurs à quoi vous faites
allusion à la mise à mort barbare en
octobre 2018 dans l'enceinte du consulat
saoudien d'Istanbul en Turquie du
dissident Jamal rachodji étouffé avant
que sa débrouille soit débité à la
disqueuse le tout avec la valve de ce
prince plus moderne de ce trentenaire
impulsif et mégalo qui séchent à coup de
chantier pharaonique à escamoter ses
égarements d'hier tel le 20 blocus du
rival catary ou plus dévastateur
l'engagement du royaume dans la guerre
au Yémen mais voilà assise sur son tas
Dorn noir la paix trop monarchie
première productrice de brute du monde
peut tous permettre y compris de défier
son protecteur américain de renouer sous
l'égide de Pékin avec l'iranchite
naguère ennemie mortelle de recevoir à
Jeddah l'Ukrainien Zelenski et
d'endosser la Baya du médiateur sur le
front soudanais et ça plaît l'Occident
selon vous cette activité
l'homme étant un animal amnésique MBS
recueille un écho indéniable Emmanuel
Macron a déroulé le tapis rouge et
lycéen sous ses pas des juillet dernier
quant au Canada de Justin Trudeau il
vient d'annoncer le rétablissement des
relations diplomatiques avec Riad tant
pis pour les militants des droits
humains persécutés tant pis pour les
femmes bâillonnées tant pis pour le
millier de terroristes appellation
contrôlée ex depuis 2015 merci en voilà
un parti pris elle il nous reste cinq
minutes on enchaîne avec vous parce que
je veux vous laisser du temps pas comme
la dernière fois Delphine carte blanche
ce soir sur cette amende historique que
va payer meta meta c'est le nouveau nom
de la grande entreprise de Mark
Zuckerberg pourquoi précisément oui 1,2
milliards d'euros c'est vraiment une
amende record et puis en plus cette
tombe à pique puisque aujourd'hui
l'Europe souffle les 5 ans du règlement
européen sur la protection des données
le rgpd donc c'est un peu cette annonce
comme si l'Europe disait comme ça au
monde entier regardez ce qu'il vous
arrivera si jamais vous ne suivez pas
nos règles alors c'est vrai que les
régulateurs n'ont pas du tout lésiné sur
cette condamnation non seulement il y a
l'amende mais ils exigent aussi de méta
des mesures très strictes Facebook doit
cesser tout transfert de données
concernant les Européens vers les
États-Unis à compter du 12 octobre et
puis le groupe a jusqu'au 12 novembre
pour rapatrier les données des Européens
qui ont déconnecté depuis 2020 alors la
question c'est est-ce que méta va
s'exécuter et ça c'est pas si sûr et
pourquoi alors c'est pas sûr parce que
principalement en ce moment il y a des
discussions justement sur le sujet de
cette condamnation entre d'un côté
l'administration américaine et de
l'autre la Commission européenne donc on
attend là dans quelques semaines
quelques mois un texte qui doit fixer un
nouveau cadre sur les transferts des
données des Européens vers les
États-Unis autrement dit avant même que
meta n'ai besoin de se plier assez
sanctions et bien cette accord Biden van
der Leyen pourrait autoriser des
pratiques qui sont jusqu'ici illégales
et les données alors pour pour nous
Européens on a de quoi s'inquiéter alors
bon ça fait quand même cinq ans qu'on
vit avec ce règlement le règlement
européen sur la protection des données
le rgpd qui impose aux entreprises de
protéger nos données numériques il a des
effets donc c'est indéniable on le voit
avec eux les amandes au niveau européen
depuis l'application du rgpd
les amendes prononcer dépassent les 2,5
milliards d'euros au niveau français on
est à 500 millions d'euros il y a
quelques jours c'est doctissimo
d'ailleurs qui a été visée rappelait
alors sur les durées des conservations
des données la collecte de données de
santé via des tests en ligne la
sécurisation des données le modèle aussi
choisi de dépôt des cookies sur le
terminal des utilisateurs enfin bref le
site français ecope ainsi de 380 000
euros d'amende donc c'est vrai que petit
à petit on voit quand que le marché est
forcé de s'adapter à ces nouvelles
règles en particulier les entreprises
européennes qui n'ont plus le choix
véritablement on en a même certaines qui
ont mis la clé sous la porte parce que
c'était trop difficile pour elle de
bouger de changer de modèle mais les big
tech elle c'est très différent elles ont
énormément de moyens pour faire face à
ces règles contraignantes que ce soit
des moyens financiers mais aussi
juridique et même politique puisque
aujourd'hui le numérique c'est une arme
géopolitique
donc face à cela c'est vrai que ce rgpd
moi il me semble encore très jeune et
surtout fragile
c'est déjà ça on peut on peut se dire
que c'est un premier pas on verra ce que
ça donnera les les grandes
réglementations européennes qui
concernent aussi cette question là
absolument certaine façon DSA et le DMA
qui vont là aussi rapporter de la
régulation en Europe bon j'ai attrapé un
petit bout de votre chronique vous m'en
voulez pas trop c'est dommage parce que
j'aurais aimé quand même rappeler que
en la matière droit de l'homme titulaire
d'un bilan bien plus accablant encore
que Ben Salman vous savez ce type aux
allures des châssis indolents il a quand
même rappelons-le il a croisé des villes
entières sous les bombes il a eu au
besoin alarme chimique contre un peuple
qui est paraît-il le sien mais c'est
vrai qu'il a deux atouts majeurs et je
fais très court là-dessus d'abord les
réfugiés un fardeau dans tous ses
voisins veulent se délester chantage et
puis le captagon une drogue de synthèse
que ses laboratoires exportent le
conteneur entier c'est à dire le clan à
la SADE qui tire les profits de ce
trafic en tout cas s'il y a une
certitude c'est que captagon ou pas
notre pauvre monde n'en finit plus de se
shooter à l'impunité et ben voilà ça
c'est une chute merci ça vous choque
vous ce retour en grâce à la salle oui
ça me choque bien entendu on peut pas
les les leçons des histoires aussi
proches en plus aussi récentes mais
évidemment on s'arrête là merci et
pardon c'est la dernière fois je jure
maître du jeu allez à demain Elsa merci
beaucoup Delphine Sabatier les derniers
jours de Samuel Paty c'est-à-dire chez
plomb c'est signé Stéphane Simon très
belle soirée documentaire à présent qui
commence avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à
demain même le même
[Musique]